en la final de la Copa de Francia el
stat de fons no será solo un campo de
batalla para nantes y tu luz otro Duelo
paralelo se estará dando entre mahón y
los sindicatos quienes pidieron al
público sacar tarjeta Rojas al
presidente uno de los asistentes al
juego previo al partido uno de los
sindicatos radicales el cgt reunió a sus
miembros frente al stated
vamos a repartir tarjetas rojas y
silbatos al público para que le den un
mensaje a macron 30.000 tarjetas rojas Y
10.000 silbatos serán distribuidos entre
los aficionados una medida criticada por
el portavoz del gobierno francés un
partido de fútbol en la final de la Copa
de Francia no es lo mismo que los juegos
de circo en la época romana no es la cgt
con su pulgar Imperial quien decidirá
así abuchear o no macron quien cortará
la luz durante el partido el estadio no
es solo un símbolo del fútbol sino del
descontento político actual en el país
durante un partido del equipo de Francia
en marzo se escuchó un pitido cuando
corría al minuto 49 con 3 segundos En
referencia al artículo 49.3 adoptado por
macun quien impulsó la reforma de las
pensiones sin votación parlamentaria el
año pasado luego de su reelección el
presidente fue abucheado a su llegada al
estadio pero al contrario de sus
predecesores mahón siempre saludaba a
los jugadores antes de cada partido
después de meses de protestas en la
capital se incrementará la seguridad con
3000 policías para mantener el orden en
el estadio esto es más que en la final
de la Champions League en 2022 además en
el interior del estadio se ha instalado
una valla Metálica con clavos alrededor
del campo para evitar que los
manifestantes accedan al terreno de
juego